just standing there for me what I've
seen so far has been horrifying so I'm
scared to death of what I'm going to
find in this kitchen what's that there
chicken with the frost Jesus Christ
almighty and it's just slime [__]
hell what does that mean when it's
slime bad yeah that's right sticky
[__]
disgusting 1 2 3 4 five
freezers and this is what you call Fresh
Food right lately had to freeze
everything it was just look what do we
actually cooking here what is
that cooked
chicken look at it feel it hold it it's
freezer bur it's dry it's it's
gone yeah it's not a [__] loofer for
your back there's the bacon oh my
Lord you are [__] kidding
me
jumble are we really in New Orleans come
on
garbage right time to take the family
want it tell you who's hungry I am let's
go this disguise pays homage to one of
my favorite comedies stinks stinks the
National Lampoon Vacation
movies is this
Eagle this is great hopefully our meal
is less disastrous than some of
vacations oh
man here we go macaronis how are you hey
can we get a table of four please sure
right this way when you walk into Bell
your first instinct is to walk right
back out set them on table 23 please I'm
sorry 43 how depressing is this Decor
the tacky decor and the uninviting staff
makes you feel immediately unwelcome you
need a few minutes or are you ready no
um nope what nope we're ready nope we
need a few minutes okay can we order
galari FR we've ordered a variety of
classic Italian dishes and spaghetti
meatballs very good I'll be right back
thank you if you can't do these staples
properly TR col bake lamp's chop first
then a family [__] salad you have no
business being in the restaurant
business I have the two appetizers yeah
go
ahead go for it so this is that's the
baked clams take one and say a prayer
let's see what I've got in mind
there crams are really salty no it
tastes like I'm eating just breadcrumbs
I had no clam in mine either so clam
with no clam did you get a
clam calamari is rubbery it's not even
crispy they taste old if you like I can
give you a little on each of your dish
if you want these clams are horrendous
okay there is not a clam okay de I'd be
more than happy to take him off the
track de you got it whatever he
wants hello yes clam sucked Hey listen
you got to stop okay I my clam sucked my
sister sucked got to stop cuz it's
[__] [__] you hear that shouting
no don't clams in the clams no nothing
there's no clam in the clam okay
whatever that's why they ate the whole
[__] thing yeah I know yeah okay tip
it up you can cook yourself yeah you got
you go cook yourself yeah I know cuz I'm
the one saying this making it up I
know yeah look at my salad this salad is
appalling look it's dead don't eat the
uh dressing H smell like the back seat
of my car spaghetti meatballs
eggplant
farm so let's say a little prayer for
the Onre dear Lord what we're about to
receive may we not end up in ER thank
you that's is horrendous oh my God oh my
God that looks like the inside of my
grandfather's Underpants that looks like
a placenta I would not feed this to my
dog how we do it this is horrendous dear
tremendous meaning you want me to take
it away you didn't like it dear it was
horrible okay great hone take it away
Daniel please you know what if you like
the whole din is on me enjoy okay okay
well you don't have to be nasty dear you
don't like anything you don't have to be
nasty I'm not nasty at all
dear thank you wow is he always was like
that he always he always
angry oh my lord it's like they're
scared of him they said the ve sucked
the eggplant sucked this sucked
everything sucks so it's [__]
[__] I'm done so [__] done it's
[__] [__] see you in a minute
nothing see enough I'll please thank you
where's Daniel you know what why don't
you buy them coffee and dessert too so
they complain about that too tell them
it's on me everything cuz our food sucks
cuz it's [__] [__] holy [__]
[__] oh man that place looks like a do
with a paint no yeah the farmers I'm
with are locals which should help me
maintain my cover hey there how are yall
but after spotting the Hideous Decor I'm
feeling a tad over Dressed Man time you
smell that huh what's that smell can I
waste that some stank in this kitchen I
ain't just going to tell y'all the truth
I don't know what it is but it's some
stank my feet are sticking to the
[__] carpet have I just stepped in
horsman holy [__] well let's justest dve
the Lon y that's the best I have to
offer meat and ters what's a t a
tater potato
potato we're ordering menu items that
should be Southern Staples let me get
the bow how the gumb the fried oysters
can I get a side pork chop I'm going to
try the uh fried catfish for with the
large fillet s flounder
mhm thank you
ma'am Bean Lo's here would you come here
we quit coming here about 3 years ago
gone
downhill Bry your appetizers are up
that's kind of
[Music]
sad thank you Jesus Christ look at that
greasy rubbery that's Terri you gumbo
man I'm going pass on the
gumbo those oyers aren shocking oh good
that's a little chewy it feels like I'm
chewing a [__] golf ball oh yeah
don't swallow that oyster a stuff ra
fer thank you
[Music]
fish thank
you look at that oh my
Lord stuffing on top of that smells yeah
catch the day Hepatitis
B little catfish for my
cler oh my Lord you think the catfish
would be exceptional wouldn't
you that is terrible taste of that it
looks likeo oh that's horrible right
there man that's not good I'm only going
to get changed okay so just uh just
trying time to eat please do Cuz I'm not
real sure how long I going to keep
eating this
serious there's something you should
know my team has been coming to this
restaurant undercover for quite some
time to find out what is really going on
I'd like all of you to take a look of
what I discovered whilst my team were
Undercover please pay attention all of
you I think the restaurant it is very
old fashion we now only had 10 people
all week I made more money when I was
[__] 16 in the kitchen it smells like
it has a
smell oh my God
what is wrong with
you oh my Lord oh oh youe that don't
laugh it's not funny what I saw in the
video was disgusting I couldn't believe
I ate there it was dis it was gross I
want to I wanted to puke don't be
[__] blaming everything on me well
why is this business going down in the
duns everyone blames me I'm sick of it a
come on any loses a t of a place it
becomes a frenzy [__]
the whole kitchen's [__] scumbag
[__] [__] jerk off listen I'm
cing my [__] imp yourself [__] you
I'm [__] stuck here destroying my
family this is what you wanted this is
was your dream it's my dream I [__]
everybody I live with that every day un
[__]
believable let me tell you something
even though it may appear that all of
you have given up maybe I'm bitter hate
ful and disgusted inside and it shows
but I never gave up don't say I gave
up it's disgusting Behavior Vinnie you
you ever feel your father every
day did you I'm asking you a question my
father died 20 years
ago okay I'm very sorry for that cuz Dad
and Mom mean everything to me if if you
failed your father everything day let me
say it the right way would you feel good
about every day going to work if would
you I'm asking you a
question when does this kitchen get
cleaned we don't do the cleaning we
don't do that [__]
terrible i've got no dates on here I've
got no [__] reference who leaves
these potatoes in there like that I'm
I'm I Char on everything your kitchens
are w Zone going to be a long
night what in the [__] is going on in
here on Monday we cooked uh three times
amount of wing we need it would you eat
that no is that the powdered gravy yes
just taste that that's what's going on
top of the shepherd's pie shepherd's pie
my ass Shepherd's shite it tastes like
airplane food look at that do you have
any idea how long that's got to sit in
there to get like that what' you do with
that but do you have any idea of the
thousands of dollars on the menu you're
throwing out yeah you're right this
business is hemorrhaging and it starts
from right in
here you can do better than this and you
too you don't have to be a top executive
chef to realize how bad this is
functioning mhm I see it so Fred you've
been running this place why would you
make the business so dysfunctional to be
honest with you I want to be out I want
to be out of the business but I just
kept me coming in out not focusing
enough on it you you better get your
[__]
together Gabby I want all your team in
here now and I want this [__] place
absolutely spotless I feel sh hey wake
up when was the last time this place was
properly cleaned the kitchen these guys
clean up every single night every single
night that's absolute utter [__] are
you looking properly or are you just TI
not of Chef so maybe would know you
don't need to be a chef to understand
the kitchen is [__]
dirty that there is every
night that's every night [__]
sake do you ever the idea how quick this
[__] can ignite
no how do we get wings like
this oh why are the brussel sprouts in
with the wings no clue to be honest H
they probably just got shuffled around
when we were running around like
chickens back here they're cooked right
they should be part cooked but when you
part cook them and there still raw in
the middle that's the most dangerous
time for a chicken right the raw
continues growing in bacteria it affects
the cook part everything it touches just
cross-contaminating
it's fundamentally
wrong where's the main walking see this
one here yeah where is that smell coming
from what is that smell oh my god oh got
a throw
unbelievable
[Music]
where is that smell coming from oh my
God what is that
now why is all this stuff sat in that
blood it's also on month old a month old
are you telling me that for sure is a
month old like you know for sure that
was a month old H probably can you two
[__] off the d i a word with
C I'm disgusting right now like no
different than you are right now I'm
completely beside myself this is your
[__] future on the line your name
your wife's name everything you've got
into this business and walking like that
you're losing thousands of dollars and
actually when you really dig in there
and you really look at everything and I
mean you know where to look I'm not a
restaurant tourist so you know where to
kind of look at it you need to stop the
excuses you need to start looking within
and you need to start becoming ACC
accountable that's clear today isn't it
I want the chefs in here and I want this
[__] place
cleaned it's
frustrating first of all where's the
kitchen this is our kitchen you haven't
even got a stove we have a
burner that's a stove a burn from
1974 what' you do on that uh we have a
skillet up there to cook our taco
meat and what is this contra
a really shitty oven but it's a
toaster so how'd you cook the pizzas we
run them through from this in they go
through that in takes about 6 to 8
minutes this is
it when was the last time these were
clean probably 2 or 3 months two or
three months or two or three
years Steve talk to me can't see it come
on there's a [__] pizza cooked in a
1980s toaster things have just been
slipping our standards just keep this is
beyond slipping
now and Brad is this how Bru is run
absolutely not how' you function like
this at a low standard it looks
like oh my go [__] disgusting justing
Steven step up here and look down
there it's lined with rat
[__] every rat in the air is dumped on
top of your [__] fridge oh [__]
disgusting not months not weeks years of
rat
[__] for the love of
God what has happened to us why are we
standing here like pigs in [__]
festering and [__] rat [__] My worry
is you're not even
drunk at least if you were slightly
drunk as a [__]
excuse what's happened to
us why are we standing here like pigs
and [__] festering [__] rat [__] My
worry is you're not even
drunk at least if you were slightly
drunk is a [__] excuse this is not a
kitchen this is a hell
hole do something you've never done roll
up your sleeves and get this [__]
place
spotless got
it I wouldn't keep anything that's been
in that fridge there's rat [__] up
there now that these owners are
realizing just how big of a job this is
we got a bigger trash can we got new
one I was watching behind the line I was
mortified to the
practices when was the last time this
kitchen was cleaned it ain't been clean
since we've been open
what it hasn't been cleaned in 8 months
I only been in charge the last 2 months
oh my
God this fridge is not even on no none
of this is working properly we got stuff
in here yes cuz I have nowhere else to
store it we can't put in the fridge it's
not working yeah but but I'm not using
it you have to take some responsibility
there needs to be accountability here
somewhere that's
moldy what's in this one here what is
that PO
por p
p smell that I can smell it pass it to
the
owner I'll C come
on three adults stand in front of me you
have to be kidding
me what's that chicken strips chicken
strips in this yep and what they for we
was cooking a for a sandwich for a salad
they fresh strips it's all slimy it's F
and
slimy what happens when it sits in
bloody water you're right this is a
[__] disaster what has happened to us
no help lack a help you don't need help
to throw that [__] away no I don't need
help to throw that away but I need help
to keep this kitchen in order you still
need to take care of everything break
down put everything away I had no idea
this stuff is jammed back there well
maybe if somebody come in the kitchen
and help Tasha out in the kitchen then
everybody know everything about
everything but when y'all leave it all
for one person to do and don't offer a
hand then this what
happen jine when was the last time you
stood behind the line actually went
through this at night I haven't I don't
know what I'm doing and I don't know
what needs to be we that's come on you
know [__] damn well that's ridiculous
that is embarrassing that is ridiculous
that [__] there you're never going to
serve to anybody this is excuse after
excuse after excuse and you can't tell
that that's [__] mold you can't tell
that that's Roden come on Jermaine [__]
off this is excuse after excuse after
excuse and you can't tell tell that
that's [__] mold you can't tell that
that's Roden come on Jermaine [__] off
yeah I'm sympathetically got no one to
[__] run this place but I'm not
sympathetic to
[__] can I have a a moment with a chef
on my own please you to in the dining
room I'm [__] I don't know what to
say
anymore can you go get them bring them
downstairs if the food I ate yesterday
is any indication I shudder to think of
the practices going on inside Okay so
the minute you go inside a walking it
gives you an indication how business is
functioning when was the last time you
cleaned this out last week last week wow
[__] hell man what's the smell in
here come on what is
that what is that it's a pork and when
pork sits in all that blood there what
happens to the pork sour
sour oh guys oh no what the [__] is
this that would be your r as and that
stays in there yep no Ladle and more
importantly no
date that was made last Wednesday last
Wednesday what do that do to food
Cynthia it spoils it it's rusty rusty
dirty [__] from a crated pan come
on what the [__] is this that would be
your gash G and that stays in there yep
Rusty dirty [__] from a crated pan come
on Mark I'm at a loss for work Chef this
is not how you run the Phoenix no sir I
know we've hit hard times I get that but
we can't run this business like we've
given up uh let's go upstairs to the
kitchen please mark That's a joke though
I don't care how busy they
are you guys see that
Tim come over I know you look disgusted
is that the [__] ey at lunchtime I yes
you probably do you believe so oh my god
oh said it was disgusting I just want
some form of responsibility somewhere
okay Cynthia can we get this place
cleaned yes Mark can I have a quick word
cynth can get cracking please yes get
[Music]
started I think we should throw this out
first all the salads salmon this as bad
as I thought it was Tim Dwayne and Doc
they need to take responsibility just
dump it just dump it we're going to get
this turn around okay I've got tons to
do down Main Street I'll pop out later
yeah thank you thanks excuse me oh boy
everything has to go to trash is that
awesome think is all worth
it thank you and my goodness me look
who's at the Forefront of that wall the
man himself your family and your legacy
yeah absolutely
[Music]
good it's the beginning of a new
generation for bto's Italian line we've
revamped the restaurant's old world
charm for the Modern Age gone are the
outdated
portraits replaced with a design that's
cozy and rustic I feel like it's so big
in here like there's so much room by
upgrading the stuffy Decor we've created
a space that's open and inviting fit for
family and friends alike I love these
lights I just think that finished it off
so pretty um now let's get all the team
in
here right okay for me this level of uh
confusion in terms of Robert and Henry
we have one person in control now and
that person is it's me we're going to
run the ship in the right direction this
is family here okay let's bring that
family feeling back let's recharge this
place and let's knock it out of the park
tonight let's set seal I didn't think I
was going to cry but for you man yep for
you for you Robert will be here tonight
but it's up to each and every one of you
to prove that he doesn't need to be here
amen 100% agree yes let's go guys bring
it in bring it in bring it in we got
this right we got this
hello sir customer set upstairs having
dinner with a Critic from USA Today an
influential
critic can you explain exactly to this
man who you are no I'm your
brother never
G man so that was your brother you just
coped for yeah my big question are you
going to support him absolutely you got
a team behind you that taught us right
okay so let's [__] do it right do you
want this absolutely I wouldn't have did
it if I didn't want it so Robert's out
he's got to stay out and I'm going to
make sure of we both are this is your
room I know that's your room right I
know no the critic enjoyed the food your
brother enjoyed the food but you need to
find that voice step up the nothing be
scared of and grab the ball by their
horse definitely will okay and next time
I come back I want to see you in charge
Gordon ramay is a hell of a
man thank you the passion he has help
people is immeasurable we keep him out
of there would you you yeah thank you
shepher he's given me the right tools to
continue my dad's Legacy and grow Bots
even bigger this family has been
severely wounded but if I can Empower
Logan we may have some direction Amber
let's have a two minutes together
please
oh man how you
feeling tired tired good tough day right
tough day restaurants are tough things
to operate yes and if there's one thing
that's going on inside your restaurant
is that it's been run by too many people
you can't use a restaurant to mend a
broken relationship it doesn't work and
the pressure it puts on Logan standing
there and his angst and his
frustration he's talking about his AR
how bad for the business she
is give me an insight to Autumn
strengths what's she good
at
um what does she walk through the door
with what does she bring to the
business give me an insight to Autumn
strengths but what does she walk through
the door with what does she bring to the
business I don't know
[Music]
you can't think of one thing and I can
see you're getting emotional because
there's no contribution turning up for
work big deal I don't think there's many
people in that business that can work
with your sister or who want to work
with
her you have to stop letting her bring
you and your children
down hey come on so important to talk
yes you have an amazing son and an
amazing daughter yes it's time to look
after each other M and sometimes that
means letting others
go think about it okay okay come here
help
okay I'm going to think about New
Beginnings the past is gone going to
start fresh and I'm not going to let
anyone stay staying in the way of
that with progress continuing on the
front of house uh AUM take a seat my
okay I now need to deal with what I
believe is seaf far's biggest problem
how are you I'm I'm good I'm okay yeah
my goal Autumn is to get this restaurant
successful I want it to be I want it to
be successful would that restaurant run
AUM better without
you I don't think I don't think so no I
just feel like I'm like ostracized
gamber is in control of everything yeah
I know she was put to be the whatever
the head manager do you think you could
run the restaurant better than
Amber yes I yes I can I spend a lot of
time here but I'm not included in
anything but there are issues there Way
Beyond the restaurant you know that yeah
it started at at our childhood and my
dad he always gave me the brunt of
everything so she wasn't anywhere near
as hurt as much oh no sir I'm I'm sorry
about that but it's almost like you're
venting and using the resturant to get
back at your
family how about this we re launched
that restaurant you take a sabatical and
we get your 20% investment coming on a
monthly basis how would that make you
feel no I don't want to take no no no
sir I don't you your sister and your mom
need to decide a Way Forward I'd have to
think about it I
guess autumn is clearly reluctant to
step away from the restaurant and at the
end of the day I can't be the one to
make that decision for this family if
this doesn't work you're taking her down
I will not fail I will not take her down
I won't no matter what sacrifice I have
to make I won't do it I am going to make
this happen with or without anyone's
help I'm going to be okay it's not
looking good yes it
is it's looking good for the fact that
we are still trying and we have not
given up if we give up now what will we
do I'm not asking you to give up Shane
I'm just asking to be reasonable and
stop being so stubborn and blinded by
the
office you are bringing your
daughters down and you've put them at
risk and over the last 18 months all
you've done is Bute heads fight and
scream and upset each other no
restaurant is worth that it's one thing
for for you to risk all this mhm but
your two daughters sat in the back seat
I'm telling you I think you'll been
unfair you're taking advantage of the
unconditional love that your two amazing
daughters show you I'm
sorry Shan's acting defensive because
she can't see her own problems she's
going to hit at brick wall soon I don't
know when but something's going to click
and she'll
understand that she is the driving force
behind this mess and the
responsibility lies with her not her
daughters Gordon I'm getting news that
Shane is leaving the restaurant right
now one thing you never do is jump ship
where is she she's in her car with her
mother oh my god let's
go
what's wrong I'm amazed you want to
throw the towel in now but tell me
what's wrong tell me what you're I mean
I feel like you've given up on us you
know you feel I've given up on you oh
that's unfair I know damn well that
you're not going to like everything I'm
doing I I I get that it's not about
rubbing your face in it it's about
helping you if you're saying Shane I
don't know about this for you you know
what I'm saying you may may you didn't
took the kids I'm trying to separate the
family from the business because there's
two different different things going on
here we have a family that's hurting and
a business is struggling if I get the
business back up to speed then the
family don't have to hurt if you think
that's been unfair I'm sorry but there's
two different things in here and with 38
restaurants and five kids of my own I'm
not going to bring them into my business
I have to separate it so if Chelsea's
there for the next 18 months right there
needs to be a there needs to be a path
set and if you don't think that's valid
then I'm I'm I'm out of here no I do I'm
sorry and I'm not rubbing your face in
it it's hard to hear I know it's hard to
hear I'm really sorry I'm really sorry
come here come out of
there come
on we are going to do this okay come on
hey you're a great man we are going to
do this I'm not going to let that family
struggle and I'm trying to separate at
the issues so you can go on holiday sir
you can have a vacation you can have a
weekend together okay Gran come here
please come on come on we are going to
save family we are going to save this
restaurant okay I'm sorry okay I'm here
to help I ask for help out loud so many
times I'm I'm I'm going to I'm going to
help I'm going to help you but I also
want to protect the family I'm really
sorry let me help you okay come
on